hey everybody welcome back to pork
attacks today I want to take a Biscayne
Beach which I've heard is one of the
most difficult scenarios and yeah this
will be my first time trying it actually
so I have no idea how this is going to
work but I do know what the map looks
like and I know that for a fact this is
one of the smallest park maps in the
game and that's probably what makes this
map so difficult so the setting is a
beach alongside the town
I always thought it's very similar to
bumbly Beach in roller coaster tycoon
except this one is actually a beach and
this is much more confined in terms of
space which actually I think is a good
thing I always thought bumbly Beach was
a bit too large and far away from the
beach itself although the Blackpool
Pleasure Beach was very obviously
influenced there but yeah we basically
have this very narrow strip of land here
and we can also buy some land here so
I'm very curious to see if we'll
actually need this but I think we do
because we need to get at least 600
guests into the park with an experiences
rating of 80% and there's also the
optional go of having a cleanliness
rating of 75 percent which I think I'll
probably mates because I don't think
it'll be easy to actually reach the
experiences rating without getting also
the cleanliness rating so I think that
should be more or less fine now I'm
actually very curious to see what kind
of research we have in this we start off
with some decent first rides actually
and a wooden coaster as well that's
awesome that's actually something that I
thought would fit really well alongside
the edge of the park here just an out
and Bank wooden coaster very space
efficient and I think it very much fits
the idea of this park as well so
honestly I think I'll start off with a
wooden coaster as a main moneymaker and
then spend any other money that I've
left on different kinds of flat rides
and go from there so let's get started
alright now I'm starting with the wooden
coaster here which is maybe a little bit
unusual rather than building a food
court first or some rides
but in my mind I wanted to build an
income as quickly as I could and
something that I didn't realize when I
started this recording just now and what
is probably the main thing
making this very difficult scenario is
the fact that you cannot charge any
money for the rides in this scenario you
can only charge for the entrance but all
of the rides have to be free so at this
point I was actually building this
wooden coaster mostly to draw guests
into the park and charge a really high
price right from the start so that in
the first few minutes of landing the
gameplay I could earn some good cash at
this moment the park is actually still
open but I'm gonna close that eventually
and once I open all the rides and I have
a basic first area finished I'll
actually really open the park with a
very hefty income or a very hefty
entrance fee just to make sure that I
earned some decent money right from the
start and yeah overall this scenario is
gonna require some very different
tactics from all of the scenarios so far
I really just need to make sure that I
can get a very high entrance fee and
also there's a lot of upfront income as
soon as you open the park and as soon as
you open new rides but once everybody's
in the park and kind of going through
all the rides you don't earn that much
money anymore so I expect that I'll be
earning a lot of money right at the
start but that pretty much in contrary
to usual situations it's just gonna
start dwindling from there so that's
something to keep in mind
now I haven't even talked about the
wooden coaster yet this is very much a
classic out-and-back woody as you'll see
on many beach side theme parks
I think Blackpool Pleasure Beach has a
lot of very similar Woody's but really
you find these things almost everywhere
they're very classic on these pier or
beachside parks so I really wanted to
get something like that in here as well
and what is a bit different is that I
opted to go for blue catwalks which from
a game perspective I think looks a
little bit better a lot of these wooden
coasters will usually have white
supports with the regular wooden
unpainted tracks and then some kind of
colored railing and decoration on the
side of the coaster but in this case
because the coloring works a little bit
differently I felt that the most similar
effects
would be reached if you make the entire
catwalks blue because you can't
separately color the railings here so
that's why the catwalks are a bit weird
like that I think it looks good though
it definitely seems to carry the sort of
traditional beachside wooden coaster
look for me so I'm pretty happy with it
and I'm also adding some custom supports
here and I really just have to use some
of these roof border pieces here because
the actual supports pieces are quite
limited just to get some head choppers
into this coaster from an inking
perspective it's probably going to help
the scenery rate in quite a bit but to
be completely honest I don't care too
much about that I really just wanted to
get the visual idea of having these head
shoppers here which is a huge part of
the fun of a wooden coaster especially
on the first half of the layout where
you're diving underneath these supports
after very long drops and that should
just make the drops themselves a little
bit more engaging I also built that
small spire on top of the litter which
is one of those classic pretty touches
but yeah starting on the actual entrance
area here with a slide which I felt was
just about the best ride to put in this
place the general layouts that I'll
follow for this build is having very
wide plazas of paths in the middle down
this strip and then putting all of the
flat rides and the coasters around that
and in the end that means that I'm gonna
be having a lot of paths but I think
that I'll help to try and make the the
park seem a little bit less crammed
because I'm really gonna have to fit
everything into very tight spaces here
so I think that should overall help make
the park look a little bit better not to
mention that I'm kind of wanting to
experiment a little bit more with my
paths again because I think the path
systems in some of the previous
scenarios especially in the first few
scenarios of this playthrough have all
been kind of similar and it's fun to
mess around with some different parts
and different colors every now and then
so I'm just using the very wide concrete
styles here and then mixing up the
colors very slightly to create some very
subtle patterns but nothing with
completely different colors or anything
dance now ii ride is the scrambled eggs
or really i guess i should be calling it
the twister i'm not even sure why these
things are called scrambled eggs if the
way that these things spin is your
method of making scrambled eggs in a pan
then i don't know how those scrambled
eggs would turn out but yeah that's
that's just what this this ride is
called for me now i decided to put a
very different roof on this one than
everything so far i'm still
experimenting with a slightly different
roof on every ride so far and i'm not
running out of ideas yet and for this
one i'm going for that
well the chest pattern that you can see
there which is very bright but i think
it very much fits the festive summer
theme of this scenario and then over
here are some very small houses that i
figured could maybe house a toilet
building and some other kind of stall so
eventually had a vending machine in
there but a temple at some point I
realized that I forgot all about space
to put a cue for the wooden coaster so
in the end I actually routed the cue
partly through this building so it's
gonna have a toilet in it but then the
rest of it is just going to be an indoor
parts of the queue for the wooden
coaster right there so I think that
works out quite well actually
to at least you know make use of the cue
because queues are one of these things
where they're kind of a waste of space
in this scenario but I do want to make
them realistically long so I want to
make sure to decorate them and put a lot
of roofs over them to at least make it
seem like they're a very important part
of the scenery of the park
anyway I'm starting to run a bit behind
at this point I was working on the food
courts which is quite necessary also if
you notice there was just a switch that
it suddenly my voice kind of changed I'm
recording this a bunch later because I
realized going through this video with
that there was another section where my
microphone decided to act really weird
and I'm still not sure how to fix this
so far I've just been switching the USB
ports but anyway that's something for me
to figure out I suppose although if
anybody does have experience with the
blue Yeti being shitty I know that's not
a new thing
but this particular brand of shitty then
please do let me know but anyway moving
on to what I'm actually doing here the
food court is quite simple although
there's an interesting quirk to it I
suppose I wanted to have a decent volume
of building here especially to block out
the view of the outside world so even
though I'm just using some stalls which
we technically just be one floor I'm
adding a top floor which is pretty much
as empty and quite airy and using the
trellis pieces as a way to decorate it
with I think it works out quite well
actually and it's a nice way to keep it
very light and simple building but still
fill up this quit the space quite well I
think for the volume of the the square
in front of it it works quite well and
then over here moving into another plaza
and a ferris wheel I am using a very
large amount of path work here just
because space is very limited in this
park and I want to actually use most of
the space just for paths so the park
doesn't get too crowded because I will
have to put everything very close
together so there'll be a lot of stalls
and queue lines and rides and coasters
everywhere so I want to have as much
pathways running in between that as I
can just to make sure that it doesn't
seem too overcrowded so that's really
the guiding principle of this park I
guess and there will just be this one
very wide pathway running down the
middle of it with these concrete
textures and some slight variations in
color to make it a bit more interesting
to look at and then the final ride that
I'm placing here for now is the good old
teacups which works out really well in
any situation so I'm adding that with a
very simple decoration around it it's
not really too interesting but I think
it works well in setting up this plaza
fond of the wooden coaster and that's
basically it for this time-lapse so
let's take a quick look into how the
park is doing
all right so as you can see I have a
huge income but I also need to say that
this is not gonna stay like this and
it's really just a temporary income
because once all of the guests are
actually in the park because all of the
money is just coming in from the
entrance I'm not gonna earn that much
money anymore so I need to keep building
stuff and drawing in more guests into
the park I've heard a lot of people who
use a trick of closing the park and
reopening it to get bursts of money in
the middle of the scenario but I'm gonna
try not to do that to stick to more
realistic approaches to be trying to
earn money as a park where you ask money
to enter the park rather than the
separate rides but I don't know maybe
I'll need to resort to it for now I'm
just gonna keep on building these flat
rides with a very wide plaza in the
middle because I don't want the park to
become too grand so I'm really
dedicating almost 50% of my land space
to paths here but also I do want to get
another coaster in somewhere or maybe
even 2 I'd like to get a junior coaster
somewhere and maybe something like as
Emperor Thunderbolts just something that
looks really good on the beach so we'll
see what I get from research and yeah
you can already tell that my income is
half of what it was when I started this
recording so you can see that it quickly
diminishes here anyway I'm gonna start
building again alright so moving on I'm
building a swinging ship in this
location and the boring answer for why
I'm doing that is because I feel like
this is one of the quintessential rides
of the theme park and whenever I go into
place the swinging ship in a park I kind
of feel like something is missing but
the more interesting answer to why I'm
doing it here specifically is because I
thought it would work quite well with
the backdrop of the coaster supports
which kind of makes for a really big
wall which you can set the the swinging
ship up against especially with some of
that scenery over the cue line it's
quite simple and maybe I could have done
something else with this I really love
it in real life when these swinging
ships are themed in some way they're a
really good ride for backdrops you know
putting some buildings on the back which
are quite tall and kind of overhanging
the queue line and
entrance think that stuff really looks
super cool but yeah here I decided to
keep it quite simple and just more
befitting with the rest of the park and
also I just kind of wanted to get this
over with because truth be told I'm also
just sort of filling this space there to
move into some things which I thought
would be slightly more interesting and
one of those is a junior coaster but
really a kiddie coaster and this is
inspired by the wacky worm layouts so
I'm trying to get some sort of basic
eight shaped layout here which is not
too easy to do especially because this
footprint is extremely small so I need
to somehow fit some of the track
underneath some of the other track and
it's not too tall to begin with so it
was a bit of a puzzle to figure out how
to lay down this figure eight but in the
end I think the very simple layout works
quite well then I eventually came up
with so yeah it's not quite the wacky
worm layouts but I don't know to me it
definitely feels the same and it looks
very similar although unfortunately the
actual wacky worm cars aren't in the
game for those who don't know what I'm
talking about wacky worm is that typical
crazy train that a lot of these small
kiddie coasters will have you especially
see them a lot on Fairgrounds and it's
it's by far one of the most cheesy
roller coaster trains ever they even
have lots of different variations I've
seen many different wacky worms with
different expressions and slight
differences it's a it's a very
interesting topic one day I would love
to see one of these roller coaster
clickbait channels or the serious
channels like theme park crazy or the
coaster studios attempt to do a top 10
wacky worm train designs video I thought
that that would be really cool but yeah
this this one isn't quite as wacky as
that is that this is just a generic
kiddie coaster with some palm trees and
a very basic station but I think it
rounds up the the roster of rides that
are available at the park quite well
and it's a good way to get another
coaster in because in the end this is a
pier park so you really want to go for
very tight rides and rides that might
even be models that come straight from
the fairground because they're always
built to be quite light and
transportable and on a very small
footprint as well so you'll see a lot of
coasters on these kinds of pier or beach
side parks that could as well be
traveling models and next to this I'm
building this Skyfall drop tower which
is just so good it's my favorite drop
tower in the world
I was basically trying to push the
research to try and get a drop tower and
I'm glad that this is what I got because
I think it fits in the park really well
and it's just such a cool right that I'd
love to place it in any park whenever I
can next to that's I'm putting the
carousel which we didn't have yet and
just like this swinging ship if you
don't have a carousel in the park I mean
there's nothing wrong with that but
personally I I really want to get one of
these in and yeah if it's available I
feel like I should place it I don't know
that's just how I personally feel about
it it's just too much of a classic even
in real life I've written too many of
these things just because it's really
fun to get on them provided that there's
not a long queue or anything because
obviously this is for the kids so they
should go first
but these things are actually still kind
of fun but yeah moving on from that this
is probably the most exciting part of
this time-lapse I'm building another
coaster and this is basically why I laid
out the park so far and this kind of
weird layouts with everything very snug
up to the wooden coaster because I once
it's a conserve space to have some kind
of launched coaster on the beach side
here now this coaster is mostly inspired
by the Zamperla Thunderbolts I believe
Luna Park has the one which was built
the first and its kind of iconic not
necessarily for good reasons I've heard
that it's really rough and not that
enjoyable but it looks really cool I
really like the out and beckley
with different inversions and some
pretty unique elements so I was inspired
by that to also make this coaster here
which I think works quite well also with
a very lengthy layout of the park so you
know wherever you're walking in the park
you'll be able to see this coaster go
around so there's a lot of interaction
between the coaster and the part which
is always good not to mention that you
know when when you have as little space
as this park here you really want to
have something that you can build in a
very compact way so launch coasters are
a bit easier in that sense because you
don't have to fit in a lift hill
somewhere you can just go straight into
the action do some inversions and come
back into a break run so yeah that's
what I'm doing here this track actually
looks very similar to the thunderbolts
track as well another track that this
that the in-game steel coaster uses is
kind of a mix between the Aero track and
the swatch copper track and kind of also
the premier track it's sort of providing
for all of these coasters at the same
time because the game doesn't have the
standard old looping coaster or the
corkscrew coaster but this coaster is
kind of both at the same time and the
track design really reminds me of the
Thunderbolt track design as well which
is the same triangular shape with these
very simple spline rail and triangular
track ties set up but yeah the layout
itself is going to be quite short
because they don't have too much space
and as you can see I'm really struggling
trying to get different elements in I
tried my best to see if I could fit a
cobra roll in but that was just not
happening so it starts off with the top
hats so it catch a bit of air time on
that and then after that you run into a
very small hill and I'm trying to make
this another very smooth dive loop very
much like the one I had in batavia key
I've recently been told it's pronounced
key and I'm very confused by the English
language now but yeah apparently it's
key so thanks for letting me know about
that yeah anyway in in batavia key I
also had a coaster where
I I kind of used the slope to build a
smoother dive loop so I'm trying to do
the same here and then after that dive
loop you have a small airtime Hill into
a vertical loop and as you might have
noticed I built the vertical loop out of
two half loops so that it actually moves
to grid spaces to the sides so the
vertical loop goes straight over the
track that goes through the middle of it
so it's bit of a strangely shaped loop
it kind of looks like the first loop on
Olympia looping which is a very wide
loop with track going straight through
the middle of it it's strange shape but
yeah it's pretty much what I have to go
for here because the the space is very
limited what I also noticed is that it
made the loop very circular because they
have loop in the game is a bit more
circular than the the full loop so I
mean if you want to go for more circular
shaped loops you can actually use two
half loops instead of one single
vertical loop because this one is not
quite as cloth or shaped but yeah that's
that's all for the layouts after that
you just go into one more air time here
on into the break runs so yeah really
it's not too long but I do think it has
a pretty decent length and you know I
think it's also just about the most I
could get out of this space here I could
have done maybe a little bit more but
then there wouldn't be enough space to
put a proper break running and I always
try to whenever I can have to break runs
they could be connected but at least
have one section which is just regular
old friction brakes to slow the coaster
down and then a section where you have
block breaks where you could leave the
second train if there's anything wrong
with the other train you know if you
want to have two trains
I always want to make sure to have an
entire flat section of block brakes on
which a whole train could be placed now
when it comes to the station I'm keeping
it quite simple with a roof in the
middle of the track which is raised a
bit and then some slightly lower and
flats roofs on the side and this basic
kind of setup is always a really easy
way to get out of doing a station and
that looks slightly interesting but you
know that it never really feels it's
pretty much a station for dumb
and you can go an experiment with any
kind of roof shape but as long as you
have that like slightly raised roof in
the center and then some lower less
steep roofs on the side it just pretty
much always looks quite good and there's
a lot that you can put in there in terms
of variation so I did experiment a bit
with the pillars and the different
wooden pieces that you see on the roof
but that aside it's a quite as standard
station and finally I'm finishing off
this section of the park with some staff
stuff and these stalls the selling
drinks and food because we're quite far
away from the other section of the park
where we have the other cafeteria and
yeah that is basically it's and with
that this park is finished so let's see
how it's doing and if I can actually
make the objective in time well guys I
think we're witnessing a miracle right
now so I'm almost reaching the goals I'm
at 78 percent experiences waiting and
that's the only go I still need to reach
I've got the cleanliness rating I've got
the 600 guests and I'm not sure if I'm
instantly going to finish the scenario
or if it's another one where we need to
hold the girls for a while actually
never mind my experience is rating just
dropped again well I thought I was gonna
make it
but apparently that might not be the
case per se anyway it's the 2nd of
September and I need to reach the goals
by the second or by the you say it's the
2nd of September it's September year 2
and I need to reach the goals by
December year 2 so by the looks of it
I'm well on my way and the experience
rating has steadily been climbing at
least it was until it just dropped down
just now but the thing about the
experience is waiting is that it's a
pole that the park will take when guests
leave the park so a happy guest doesn't
necessarily increase your experiences
rating because they need to leave the
park and fill in the survey before they
can have any
facts on the rating so it's it's not
very live so it kind of lags behind you
know and and I've heard that a lot of
people have actually been doing a trick
to just close the park and let the
experiences rating go up as the happy
people are leaving the park but yeah
that's something that I want to try not
to do although maybe I end up having to
do that anyway because I'm not actually
sure how to increase the experiences
rating beyond the point where it
currently is I think most people are
pretty happy about everything yeah the
most thoughts are just that the scenery
is great the Raptors are cute and that
stuff is worth the money so really I'm
not too sure what else Oh
toilets are disgusting I guess well I
guess I could get more janitors to fix
that issue but yeah that's the only
negative thing I've found so far like
pretty much everything is going smoothly
so yeah it's it's it's quite difficult
to get the experiences rating of at
least 80% within the time that you have
especially because I'm not entirely sure
you know how to get it up I know in
general it all just depends on the
different rights that you have to what
extent you're able to satisfy the needs
of the guests whether the park is clean
and tidy whether there's good scenery
whether you've got you know entertainers
and everything it's just in general a
good experience so it pretty much covers
every single thing in the game and
that's what makes it so difficult I
think that's and the fact that it's
something that's tested as guests leave
the park in the meantime though I think
it'd be fun to follow along and actually
do some on rides of some of the coasters
I'll do the woody like this just because
I don't look at it from the seaside
because then a lot of the layout is
hidden after these huge hills but yeah
it's a pretty standard out and bank
woody although I do have to say it's
pretty fast as well and yeah it catches
some crazy airtime on some of these
hills this one's quite okay with this
this is quite snappy here and then this
little hill here
just like hoof crazy ejector video
altogether it's a pretty fun layout and
it also has some pretty good stats if I
remember correctly yeah extreme
excitement so that's quite good
as always and the experience is rating
is 80%
so I mean do I have to wait for the end
of the month for this to pass or how
does that work now whatever whatever the
case I do want to do a quick on ride
video of the launched coaster as well ah
there we go so we've made it with all of
the goals reached even the one that
demands you to do everything before
certain time so that's awesome but yeah
this is just the layout for the coaster
and we have that dive loop and it's just
so smooth I love that way of doing that
loops and the the weird wide loop over
the other track into zero zero which I
totally forgot to mention when I was
naming off the elements and the final
airtime Hill so yeah altogether I think
it's a pretty decent layout that manages
to get all of the basic elements into a
small layout not to mention it has four
airtime moments which are all quite
strong and yeah also looks like we need
to hold the goals at 100% completion but
at the very least I made it and I don't
think yeah I don't think I'm gonna be
dropping underneath eighty percent again
let's see what it is at the moment
eighty-three percent already so yeah
it's getting better and better just
because people are leaving the park at
the moment I think yeah so here you can
see all the recent ratings people who
just left the park and left all of these
positive experiences so I'll be back in
a second once these three weeks are over
and we'll move on to whatever the next
Park I'm gonna do
and that's it all right awesome so yeah
this is Biscayne Beach for me really
quite a small park so it's not even too
much to talk about here just have this
one lengthy path leading down the middle
with all these different rollercoasters
around the sides but I'm really quite
happy with how this park turn out
especially given the very limited space
that you get here moving around with the
confetti is quite cool actually I never
realized that it's not just the simple
overlay it really seems to be quite like
the 3d but yeah I'm quite happy with
this park it's very simple it's not
quite as out there as some of the other
parks when it comes to the scenery but I
think it works very well for the map
that were given here all right so this
is what we get as a trophy one of the
houses that were standing alongside the
park which really makes sense I mean I
wasn't expecting anything else there and
I don't know if I'm gonna get a new
scenario or if it's just gonna link -
yeah it's just gonna link two scenarios
that are already gods but we do have the
Golden Circle here because I've done all
of the objectives that's pretty cool and
yeah the next ones are gonna be either
orchard acres or honey Hills and I'm
really not sure which one of these I'd
rather play at the moment I'm just gonna
see next time whenever I feel like so
yeah anyway thanks for watching and I
hope to see you guys in the next video